Low Freak bitches and then there was
another time when I had to get permission
to discern bad.
One of my cameramen from the US army,
Jake,
camera guy from Australia that I hired
who lives there and I had a decent bet
him from the US army because he was
going on a mission with the Afghans.
When you say he lives there,
he lives in Afghanistan.
In Kabul.
Whoa.
He's a war is a war journalist.
She lives there all year round.
Yeah,
and now he's moving to places
where he can cover isis.
He's an interesting guy and so and so.
Jake had to embed with the Afghans and
I had to go meet with a general to get
permission to get him in bed
with the Afghans [inaudible].
There was no US forces on the ground
where he was going and it was a place
called the Tangi Valley.
Very Dangerous Valley.
The site of the law,
single largest loss of life
of US service members at 38,
died in a Chinook that was shot down by
RPG in that valley and it was a really
important mission because the
Tango Valley is just outside Kabul,
but it's a Taliban stronghold so they can,
they can plan their operations and
attack cool very quickly from the tiny
valley.
And so it was important that we told
the story and so I went to talk with the
General Townsend and he said,
okay,
so you know,
are you prepared to see your camera guy?
Um,
you know,
in an orange jumpsuit on his knees,
on the Internet because the
place you're putting in,
that's the kind of thing that happens
and nobody's going to go get him.
No,
no US allies or us,
we'll go get him.
And I said,
I hadn't said yes.
And that was probably the hardest
moment because I had to make a conscious
conscious decision.
Right?
Then just say yes.
Did you express this to him?
Yeah,
I mean,
Jake,
Jake knows jake.
Jake knew Jake's.
Jake's.
Did you tell him that?
That that was the sentence.
That was the way it was described to you.
Yeah,
I did.
What did he say?
No problem.
Ricky and his cheerful
Australian attitudes.
No problem.
Fucking Australians.
They're crazy,
crazy,
crazy
bull.
This guy,
he's a boy.
Wow.
Sounds like a nutty dude.
What,
what motivates that guy?
Jake?
Um,
was in the Australian army and I
think he was involved with some,
some event that was really
traumatizing involving,
you know,
some kids getting hurt and killed.
And so it was somewhere in Indonesia
where the Australians were I think.
And so he ever since has been
involved ever since that event.
And then a left the army,
he's been trying to tell the story of
how war affects kids and so he's got a
special focus on kids and so that's,
that's what motivates jake,
I think.
And he,
he does this three 65.
He's over there all the time.
All the time to some
yearn for a normal life.
No,
he actually learns for the next gunfight.
He yearns for the next gunfight.
He,
he's one of those guys that chase has
gunfights around the world who looked just
all sorts of sexual appetites and
I know there's guys I know guys
don't like to be smacked
around and tied up.
I really,
I have a friend who likes
doing that fucking weird shit.
Oh yeah.
I used to work for a dominatrix.
I wasn't working for her as a Dominatrix,
but she,
I worked in her clothing store and she
was also a dominatrix this German woman
and she would go piss on people.
She would just like,
it was so funny and she had this
crazy accent and she'd answer,
you know,
one line she was ordering,
fabric and then the other line she's like,
what are you into?
Do you want me to jog around the block?
You on my feet smell.
He actually,
she always like.
And then she had a guy
who had like his thing,
she would tell me about it all.
She had a guy who all he wanted to do,
she had to wear white underwear and he
just wanted to use a flashlight and look
up her skirt for like an hour.
She would get paid so much.
At one time I went over to her house to
get paid and she had a man blind folded
on the floor crawling and he was just
smelling her boots while she was writing
me a check.
I mean,
it was,
it never ended.
It was so funny.
Did you ever hear the Central Park Story?
It wouldn't be annoying.
No,
this is a class three.
Here we go.
Tell this story.
Crack my fingers.
Okay.
We,
uh,
we're coming out of somewhere,
maybe a 12 step meeting or whatever,
you know,
and there's a hot hot black chick
walks by and recognizes me from.
And I wasn't even maybe from a club.
I didn't.
Maybe I did one TV show her two when
my life should I show it to her?
Do you want to go out for,
for bagels?
Were going for bagels.
She said,
okay.
So we went and had bagels.
Then we said,
hey,
we're going to go uptown to the people's,
you know,
on like 50,
fourth,
whatever abroad.
Like,
look,
I'm not trying to prostitute,
I'm not fucking judge.
And people,
we're not here to judge.
But I mean,
did you know she was a prostitute?
She wasn't a prostitute.
But you invite her to a Pete booth?
Yeah,
we are.
She's already likes her.
So
she got up.
She already got her.
She already got a fucking free Bagel.
Not Thinking this is going to
be your girlfriend someday.
No,
no,
no.
Uh,
but you've got to sell it to Larry.
So we go,
hey,
we're going.
We were planning on them in order to.
Anyhow,
so we go up to the quarter,
moved to people and she comes
into a booth when Mayo and,
but we get kicked out the
fucking Indian fucking get out,
you know?
No couple.
No,
no couples in the booth
in those quarter boots.
You can't bring somebody in.
So now she's no fucking lie.
I'm not lying or standing
right across from the Ed Sullivan Theater.
Right.
And there's like a newspaper Kiosk and
we're leaning on a car and I'm making out
with her and,
and,
and um,
fingering her on Broadway shows.
She fucking and nortons just grabbing
her ass like a little fucking like he's
like,
it's a toy,
right?
So I think.
And she comes in,
she has an orgasm standing
on Broadway from leaving.
So then we get in the car.
We go,
hey,
Julie has an orgasm.
Who Does?
Allegedly.
No,
I had no idea to tell.
You could feel it.
Well she didn't piss on my finger,
but you can.
But you can tell when a girl is asking.
She wasn't faking it.
She wasn't in a rush.
Okay.
Sell.
It was a way,
you know.
I'm not saying that was the best one
that has been tired of your finger.
There might still be a little fingers.
Know what they're doing.
Okay,
but you're being Nikki negative.
This is
just trying to get a real clear
picture of what actually happened.
It couldn't be any clearer.
Your finger.
That must have looked like a site also,
by the way,
just like when you went back and they
heard in the middle and then Norton
grabbing the butt.
But yeah,
no worries.
We'll confirm all of it.
Okay,
so then we go,
let's take a ride up to central park
and we were walking through central park
and then she's blowing me,
right.
She's blowing me and
then I looked down and I,
she'd Norton eating her ass for
the sake of little kid in candy.
Right.
And I'm trying not to crack
up because I'm fucking blown.
You don't want to fucking
laugh as you didn't block,
you know.
But this has got to feel good for her.
She's getting her ass eaten and,
and now I'm getting blown.
So I shoot a load,
we get back in the car and we're driving
and I go to norte and you have a good
time.
He goes,
it was a little uncomfortable.
I got my,
my,
my pants dirty.
I go,
you'll fucking eat out.
A strange girl say yes,
but you're worried about
getting your fucking pants.
What are you going to get home?
Your mom was going to say,
look at these grass stains.
Were you eating out as to get annoyed?
Like he was upset that he got grass
stains on this pants as he was eating
fucking strange girl to this.
So hilarious.
That's so sounds like norton to.
It's so ridiculous.
I mean this is obviously single and young.
Weakest so fucked.
You know,
he was dating this girl that was so
fucking hot and we're in a car and she was
blown Norton's walking by and go,
hey,
you want to watch?
And He.
He goes,
yeah.
He comes in and he's
in the back of the car.
She just fucking,
you know,
we picked up this fucking jerking off.
She's blowing.
Yeah.
But I come so quick.
He goes,
fuck man,
hold off.
One time we pick up this hot.
I pick up.
It's always made,
period.
I picked up this.
Go up under the economy of fucking.
So we're going back to Norton's house
and she's blowing me and whatever.
And nortons jerking off
and next thing you know,
I see a load fly and hit norton
in the fucking head from you.
Like he fucking,
she's blown me Jersey and a fucking.
I don't know why.
Yeah.
He hit himself in the head and I was so
fucking impressed that as soon as that
high and hit herself and then I was like,
it was fucking very impressive.
Okay.
God,
he's a creep.
What about you?
Just getting blown.
I live TV and I didn't do anything wrong.